a causa exata do aumento da Próstata é
desconhecida mas o controle principal é
pelo sistema endócrino sistema hormonal
vários fatores hormonais influenciam os
principais é a queda da testosterona o
aumento da dihidrotestosterona ou DHT
também o aumento do estradiol o chamado
hormônio feminino esses três fatores em
conjunto vão contribuir para o aumento
do órgão ou seja queda da testosterona
aumento do DHT e aumento do estradiol É
nisso que acontece com homens mais
velhos a partir dos 50 anos de idade
também vai acontecer uma queda da
apoptose que que é apoptose é morte
celular programada Isso vai acontecer
dentro da próstata essa queda da Morte
celular programada isso vai contribuir
para o aumento da próstata